Typically you're going to
spend the first eight months
on some form of a road show.
This is where you, you yourself, or
you and your business partners, or
just your business partner, will
travel to different investor groups,
and possibly trade shows looking for new
investors, and basically do the pitch.
Here's what we're doing, here's what
we believe, here's the course we're on,
here's why we feel we'll succeed,
and here's why we need your money.
And once you've done that for, anywhere,
five to eight months,
you'll get a few bites.
And those bites lead to meetings.
And those meetings whittle
down to one key, core meeting.
That first investor who's going
to open their checkbook and
give you a wad of cash.